nous devons trouver notre chemin pour sortir d'ici
tu veux me dire où diable nous
allons
Manhattan
Jésus-Christ
peux-tu au moins me dire ce que
tu fais ici il y a quelques semaines
j'ai été attaqué
ils ont emmené ton enfant
merci
as-tu vu cet homme qui s'appelle
Negan,
comment puis-je comprendre cela Maggie
l'homme qui a son émission tu le connais tu as
besoin de moi
est sur l'île
[Musique]
nous ne te connaissons pas tu es sur l'île
tu n'as pas  ne t'en tire pas,
il s'assure que c'est la vraie raison pour laquelle
nous sommes ici donc tu veux aller dans le
cycle où nous pouvons t'aider avec l'
étranger,
qu'est-ce que c'est que
je ne sais pas pourquoi tu es avec cet homme que je
cherche  car
mais je t'atteindrai,
la fin est tout ce qui compte,
je pense que tu vas l'aimer ici,
petit étranger